- [Interviewer] So our last
talk was so fucking interesting.
- [Sharky] Yeah.
Yeah, it was.
It was interesting.
Now look at me today.
- [Interviewer] So, so...
- [Sharky] I'm all fucked up.
- [Interviewer] What the
fuck happened to you?
- Well, last night,
I went home,
I went to one of my spots,
and I went to go talk to
my home girl yesterday,
and I seen somebody that, um...
- [Interviewer] That doesn't look good.
- Yeah, it doesn't look good at all.
- [Interviewer] How's your eye?
- I don't know, it feels like it's flat,
and it just keeps bleeding
and bleeding and bleeding.
This fool rolls up,
says hey, Sharky, I need to talk to you.
For what?
For what reason?
See, it still leaks blood.
And I'm like, for what reason?
I need to talk to you.
All right, cool, whatever, you know,
like normal.
We go to the back,
he starts asking me questions, like,
hey, you know, did you go through my shit?
Like, nah, I didn't go through your shit.
And he's like, I'm gonna ask you again.
I'm like nah, I didn't
go through your shit,
I have no reason to
come through your shit,
this is not my spot, you know what I mean?
And he said, are you sure?
I'm like, yeah.
Well, he turns around
and walks away from me,
and by this time I'm like, fuck it,
so I turn around and walk away,
and he tells me, hey, Sharky!
I turn around and he hits me, bam!
So I hit the ground.
I barely hit the ground,
and then it starts,
and then they all just go at me.
- [Interviewer] Oh,
there was more than one?
- [Sharky] Yeah.
Yeah , so, they go at me.
Now I'm like,
feeling like I gotta fight
for my life right here, no?
I'm in a dark spot, I don't
know what's gonna happen,
I don't know if he's gonna kill me or not.
But one keeps telling them, get the stick,
get the stick, get the stick.
And the stick, it ain't
no stick, you know?
I'm thinking, fuck,
these fools are gonna smoke
me right here, you know?
So I'm trying to get up, trying to get up,
they won't let me up.
I try to get up, I sit up,
I turn around and get
kicked in the face, bam.
Now I'm down.
Now I'm on my stomach,
trying to block everything, you know?
And it just felt like
it's just not gonna stop.
And then it's just like,
I'm thinking about my sister, my mom,
everybody, you know?
It was crazy, but it was like, fuck it,
it's like, I had a dream about this,
or something like this,
that this was gonna happen, you know?
Yeah.
I had a two year old daughter, you know?
I don't ever bring it up.
(sighs)
Yeah, so.
Serious.
Yeah.
Yeah, she was the best thing
that happened to me, you know?
But...
I don't want to be getting
high, you know? (sniffs)
I don't know, she's got a...
We were all at home.
My girl says, I'm gonna go to the doctors.
I said, all right, that's
fine with me, that's fine.
Go ahead, go to the doctors.
I'll watch the baby.
Well, I fell asleep on the couch.
She's running around, I can hear her,
she's running around, you know?
She's like, not running around,
but she's like, you know, I can hear her.
And then I remember there's
a candle on top of the,
I don't know what it's called, like,
for the, where the fireplace goes?
- [Interviewer] Oh yeah, the mantle.
- Yeah.
My girl had a, like a,
I don't know what it
was, it was like a fabric
and I guess she pulled it?
I don't know what she did,
but I heard something fall.
But like I said, I was asleep,
she was in that little
walker thing (feet shuffle)
so I didn't, she walked, I
don't know where she went,
she went somewhere so I couldn't hear her,
but I guess the thing had
fell and was draped on her,
like on the plastic, on the little thing,
and she's rolling, I guess,
and she just caught fire.
- [Interviewer] She caught on fire?
- Yeah.
I just heard her screaming and crying,
and I just woke up, and I was like,
what the fuck is going on?
And the room was on fire,
and I was throwing water
everywhere, you know?
I don't wanna talk about it no more.
(sighs)
- [Interviewer] How
many years ago was this?
- This was probably like four years ago.
(sniffs)
Yeah.
I don't even really wanna talk about it.
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- Feels like all this
shit's coming back to me,
you know?
I just feel like
everything that I've just,
I don't know, I don't
know what to do no more,
I'm just, I'm getting to the
point where I'm just like,
I'm done, I'm tired.
(lighter flicks)
- [Interviewer] You're
still young, though.
- Yeah, I'm done,
I just feel like I'm
just done with this shit,
all this shit that's going on in my life,
it feels like, fuck, I didn't
do all this shit in my years,
how the fuck did I do
all this time, you know?
(sniffs)
It's like...
It's like, fuck, when can I get a break?
Now I have to be like this.
I think I lost my eye.
I can't do my welding no more,
it's like, fuck,
like, what else is gonna go wrong?
And I was just talking
about that the other day.
But I tell you, like, there's
an eye for an eye, you know?
Don't think this is over.
It's not right at all.
- [Interviewer] Gotcha.
Thank you for coming down again.
- I appreciate it, no problem, you know?
- [Interviewer] Nah, we appreciate it.